hi I'm Saul evermore I'm a professor of
law and economics at the University of
Chicago and it's my good fortune to
introduce you to the subject of
economics well what is economics let's
play a game of free association I say
economics you say whatever comes to mind
economics money economics Wall Street
housing bubble prices incentives ooh
if you said incentives that's pretty
sophisticated I think it's easy to see
why economics is relevant economics is
everywhere economics is why buildings go
up economics is why cookies cost three
dollars economics is about getting a
seat you want on a plane economics is
yeah it's about making money
but it's about human behavior in general
economics is - the real world around you
as a meteorology is - the weather it's
interpreting all the phenomenon and
figuring out if there's anything we can
do about them economics is formally at
least the study of the allocation of
scarce resources you don't have enough
of something a lot of people want it who
gets it how do they get it what do they
give for it how do you get people to
make more of the thing all that as
economics economics likes to assume just
to make its job easier that people are
rational you know what it what is a
rational person the rational man is the
guy who sees that the price of wheat
Rises he gets up earlier in the morning
and grows more wheat on his farm the guy
who buys more of something when the
price drops
that's the rational man the rational man
loves to download stuff from iTunes when
iTunes price goes down but the rational
man also creates more music in his
garage and sells it when he gets paid
more by people who download it from
iTunes
one guy wants the price low one guy
wants the price high they're using
incentives to communicate with one
another
economics is also about puzzles and
these puzzles or even deep mysteries
have a lot to do with how economics got
started in the first place
Kings would be really confused about
some things they would issue new coins
the coins would go out into the realm
and the coins would disappear where were
these coins going Peter the Great
beheaded some thousand people for
hoarding coins and he could never figure
out why when he issued silver coins
people would hide them or burry them in
the field why didn't they want to use
these coins what was so great about
holding them
how come countries traded some things
and not others England and Portugal was
sending wine and cheese back and forth
but some things never seemed to travel
you know why was that well out of these
puzzles came the study of economics and
the people who advised these kings can
be thought of as the first economists
and economists have continued to like
puzzles ever since two of the things
we're going to focus on today are prices
and the form of competition and let me
say a little bit about them before we
get there prices are these things that
tell people how much something costs how
much they have to sacrifice to buy it
how important is to make more of the
thing we're going to see a lot of prices
today buy form of competition I mean the
people who make these things are they
competing with other firms to make it or
are they the only one out there making
it when they have the only one out there
we call them a monopolist and we're
going to spend a good deal of our time
today understanding what's so
interesting about monopolies why
governments care about them why
governments sometimes even like
monopolies and why you and I might not
like them so much prices and competition
or its opposite Napoles are two central
tools in the study of economics these
are the tools that we're going to be
looking to use to solve problems we want
to understand the recent financial
crisis that hit the world we want to
understand housing bubbles we're going
to start with prices we're going to
start with competition and then we're
going to understand the role of the
government so let's start with prices
prices do everything prices tell oil
companies when to dig deeper for oil
prices tell me you went to fly prices
tell me when to fill my car with gas
prices tell me whether to go to a
restaurant early or go to the restaurant
late and in fact when the restaurant
doesn't offer price differentials I'm a
little disappointed sometimes on a rainy
day I think oh yeah I bet there's nobody
going out to the restaurant now
I wish the restaurant would drop the
price and then I'd be more eager to go
to the restaurant so sometimes we have
prices and sometimes we don't but when
we have them they're a little bit like
magic now this magic can be a little bit
puzzling and indeed prices have puzzled
economists for hundreds if not thousands
of years you know what our things cost
what they do now say I you know eat a
chocolate chip cookie
what is that cookie cost a dollar well
first let's see the puzzle associated
with it you might be inclined to say
well a really big cookie cost more
people really like it well you might say
the more important the thing is the more
it cost if I say a house costs $300,000
and a cookie cost a dollar why does the
house cost more than a cookie your
initial response might be well people
need houses more the cookies are luxury
therefore the house cost more but that
that's not really a successful way to
think about it
think of the following classic example
air air is basically free and then
things like a diamond are classically
super expensive economists used to say
why is a diamond more expensive than a
breath of air well you already know the
answer the answer you should say is
scarcity there are very very few
diamonds you have to dig deep in the
ground to get the diamond transported
thousands of miles
Pawel should cut it do this do that it's
a lot of work it's very hard to get them
there aren't many of them air it's
available you just breathe it in let's
go back to cookies and houses now that's
a little bit more complicated
let's do cookies first I love a GU
cookie imagine that I would pay $10 for
a really fantastic juicy chocolate chip
cookie now I never pay $10 for a cookie
even
no I would if I go to a bakery even my
favorite bakery and I walk in and I say
oh how much of those fantastic cookies
the Baker knows that I would pay $10 for
the cookie he can see all over my face
but he says well I cookies $3 why
doesn't he charge me $10 I mean he might
check out my face when I walk in and
charge $10 but of course if he did that
I would just go out to the sidewalk I'd
wait there I'd wait for somebody else to
go into the bakery and buy the cookie
for $3 they would come out I'll give
them three dollars and five cents or
something for the cookie so sometimes we
say the Baker is unable to price
discriminate among people well that
doesn't answer the question of why the
cookie costs three dollars so imagine
the cookie sells for $5 the Baker sees
there's some people who really want the
cookie Baker starts raising his price
charging five dollars what's the next
thing that will happen well other people
will see you can make a lot of money
running a bakery just gather together
chocolate chips rent and oven get some
flour get the other ingredients
necessary for making chocolate chip
cookies and you'll start making cookies
and the price will start dropping as
more and more people offer cookies
they'll undercut one another 454 399
until the price goes down to well to the
amount that it'll cost that marginal
bakery to produce that chocolate chip
cookie in the short run if there's a lot
of demand for the cookie the price might
rise there's suddenly 100 people like me
rushed into the store and say we all
want the cookie maybe the Baker can
raise the price a little bit in order to
allocate the cookies that are there but
if that keeps happening new bakers will
enter the industry bakeries will be
popping up at all all up and down the
street and cookies will drop to $3 which
is the cost of producing them so prices
of inputs are signaling the Baker how to
make the cookies the price of the cookie
is signaling me about buying the cookie
and my desire for the cookie is bringing
new competitors into the industry in the
long run the price of that cookie will
be the cost of combining the inputs
let's compare it to that house say you
have a house selling for $300,000 what
does that mean it means that builders
trying to put together
those and bricks and doors and roofs and
sub-zero refrigerators or whatever goes
into the house they put all those things
together and maybe there's great demand
for housing
maybe incomes have risen maybe a war has
come to an end maybe somebody can sell
that house for five hundred thousand
dollars if so new building contractors
will come in just like bakers came into
that previous market they'll start
selling more houses they'll build houses
they'll work overtime and they'll build
houses and build houses and the price of
housing will drop again until in
equilibrium we say that marginal builder
can produce house just like that for
$300,000 price won't drop any further
because by assumption no Builder can
show up and put together those inputs
for less than three hundred thousand
dollars prices are little messengers
that run back and forth when the price
of the house went up to five hundred
thousand dollars It was as if messengers
had run out and said to builders quick
work over time build more houses they
said to the brick kilns produce more
bricks when the price started dropping I
imagine a lot of empty houses all over
the place
messages will run around and say houses
are now selling for $300,000 or less
because there's a glut of houses
Builders won't get up in the morning to
build houses no need to pound that
hammer if you're not going to get paid
for it the same thing for the baker the
price is run back and forth telling the
bakery's when to produce more cookies
when to produce fewer cookies when to
open new stores and so forth so in the
long run the answer to the question of
gee why is that house more expensive
than that cookie the answer to that is
that in the long run that's the cost of
the inputs of putting those things
together it just costs more for the
earth in a sense to produce the house
than to produce the cookie economists
like to use the word demand to refer to
the consumer side of the transaction how
much do people want the cookie how much
do people want the new houses prices are
probably the best way of measuring the
intensity with which people prefer
something the more people would pay the
more the good was in demand what we saw
though was that in the long run for
competing objects like cookies in a
bakery houses on the housing market in
the long run it was the cost of
supplying them Amanda
most but there are exceptions to this
imagine a trendy fashionable handbag the
cost of a designer putting together this
handbag might really be $40 but the
handbag might sell for 10 times that now
that's a kind of exceptional market it's
worth thinking about what's going on
there
there are knockoffs of course and the
very same designer can produce more
handbags but in the short run the
designer seems to figure out that
selling this handbag for $400 way above
the cost of the inputs that is the cost
of assembling the handbag somehow
triggers a market the higher price and
this end seems to attract people to the
good for a while because it's a fashion
trend or a signal to them that this is a
hot item to buy there are people who
want to carry this handbag because it's
unique or there are people who maybe who
are even signalling look I can afford a
$400 handbag same thing with sneakers
you know I have boring running shoes and
even more boring shoes and I pay you
know maybe $80 for them all around me I
see colorful trendy Footwear that's
actually cheaper to assemble just a
canvas and a rope practically but the
costs much more money than that again
why is that well that's the demand side
that there's a short term fashion trend
in a way where people really want the
thing thousands of it ma they need to be
allocated they're allocated by the price
mechanism the higher price and this end
seems to attract people to the good for
a while because it's a fashion trend or
a signal to them that this is a hot item
to buy again that doesn't last long
there could be a bubble for something
like sneakers the price could go way way
way up before more sneakers flood the
market or the fashion goes out I don't
think it will ever find a bubble for
chocolate chip cookies now that is
basically based on the cost of
assembling the cookie and many many
other people can enter the industry and
produce the cookie and drive the price
down it's hard to imagine a sustainable
bubble for cookies handbags some kinds
of housing certainly sneakers they can
be sold for a period of time at above
the cost of putting them together and
it's something we need to keep track of
let's think about the recent housing
bubble we experienced I think we all
have the same
picture which is housing prices were
going up and up people were borrowing
more and more money on these houses
banks perhaps we're too free to lend
money giving people mortgages on houses
that might not have been so valuable and
eventually the housing market collapsed
people were left holding houses that
really weren't worth the amount of money
they borrowed
people were walking away from the
mortgages banks were in trouble that was
colossal financial failure big Wall
Street firms were in trouble the
government thought it had to step in and
so forth how could such a housing bubble
occurred if economics is so good if
these prices are these clever little
messengers I've described why didn't
these messages do their job why don't
they run back and forth and say well the
price is too high
don't buy housing don't construct more
instead we have people all over the
country building houses even though
houses are now decaying empty in Nevada
California Florida and elsewhere
something went wrong and maybe
economists are to blame first let me
defend economists you might say how can
economists not see the housing bubble
economists are no better at predicting
future fads and meteorologists are
predicting the weather next year or
physicists are predicting where I'll be
in two weeks economists are very very
good at knowing if the price of a week
goes up now here's what will happen
tomorrow and they're very good at some
long term forecasting too but knowing
what will happen in the long run in a
housing market turns out to be very
complicated one reason it's complicated
is that people are not just buying
houses to live in them they're buying
houses as an investment they're buying
houses because they're afraid that if
they don't buy a house the house will go
up in value and they won't be able to
afford the same house later on they are
in a sense speculating and housing easy
even as they're also living in it it's
very tricky to figure out people
speculation because it's about their
psychology of everyone thinking prices
are going up I better buy buy buy now
and that's what we mean by a bubble we
mean that people are afraid to stay out
of the market because they're afraid
prices will rise so they buy the item in
question or they see everyone else
making money they think I'll make money
too but then the price ends up having
little to do with their actual demand
for the product that is their actual
preference for it and certainly has very
little to do with the actual cost of
assembling
inputs some people have faith that
governments can intervene and control
these bubbles you know in the housing
case the government did not see the
bubble coming any more than the private
market saw it coming so there's a lot of
disagreement there among economist about
where the governments are part of the
problem a part of the solution in
bubbles again though that's something
you need to study in the future because
we can't afford too many bubbles in your
lifetime couple Thanksgivings ago I was
sitting on a packed airplane I was lucky
enough to have an aisle seat sitting
next to me was a really nice tall very
tall student named Todd and we chatted a
little bit and he asked me listen how
about trading seats with me for 50 bucks
you know I'm a really big guy I'm six
foot eight these middle seats cramped me
I really really want an aisle seat so
every time I get on a plane I'm in a
middle seat I try to bargain with the
person next to me to get the aisle seat
so I can stretch out my legs 50 bucks
I said sure I think about Todd a little
bit in the study of economics we saw
that economics is about the allocation
of scarce resources
well the scarce resource is the aisle
seat there are fewer aisle seats than
people who want them now also there's no
market Todd wishes there had been a big
market out there where you got on the
plane or you got on your computer and
you saw which seats for available which
seat you want and you could bid for your
seat
Todd apparently was willing to pay $50
to get an aisle seat but at least so far
no airline is saying oh you can move to
the aisle seat if you give me forty
seven dollars and 80 cents so Todd was
trying to create the market on his own
of course it's a complicated market in a
sense he had to create two markets he
has to sell his middle seat and buy an
aisle seat now people do that on Wall
Street and they make hundreds of
millions of dollars on Wall Street we
call it arbitrage they look for things
that they think are mispriced where you
can make money by selling one thing and
buying another thing and maybe doing
them backwards and forwards many many
times a day that's in a way what Todd
was trying to do except he didn't have a
well developed market Todd wish that had
been these markets but instead he had to
make them he was trying to arbitrage
middle seats and aisle
so we've been talking about cookies and
about houses and they are sold in
competitive markets by competitive
markets I don't mean anything
complicated just that there are many
buyers and sellers running around trying
to service one another get the business
buy the thing at the lower price and all
that those markets are the foundation of
economics economist spent a lot of time
on competitive markets but not
everything is sold in a competitive
market and maybe less so than ever
for example nonprofits occupy the
healthcare field nonprofits are
important in education nonprofits are
important in supplying goods to poor
people and so forth governments are not
competitive firms to be the monopolist
or something else government's supply a
lot they supply national defense and
firefighting and national parks and
schools and this and that and then
they're also monopolists novelists again
are single sellers traditionally they
have a market all to themselves
think about all the monopolists that we
know ipads are sold in monopoly markets
because Apple has patents on critical
aspects of the iPad
let's examine those prices and messenger
systems a little bit more carefully by
thinking at the same time of an example
where the airline is now not a
competitor where many many airlines are
flying but let's now begin to introduce
the idea of the monopolist that is the
seller who does not face competition but
is the only one selling these seats
let's try an example together do you
remember Todd on the airplane
imagine that Todd was flying on a plane
and to make the example as simple as
possible imagine the plane was owned by
an airline called big air for lack of a
better name and that big air was the
only carrier flying between the two
cities Todd and I were traveling say was
Boston to LaGuardia Airport in New York
so I have a chart here I've of course
made it up but it's a pretty realistic
chart in a way and it shows that as big
air charges more and more four-seat on
the airline fewer people will want to
travel on big air either they won't
travel to New York or they'll drive take
the train walk dunkey what-have-you but
let's have a look at it if they charge
to see 10,000 people want to fly to New
York that day Wow
if they charge $5,000 a seat basically
no one wants to go 10 spoiled snobs will
fly and there there you go on the bottom
$5,000 prize 10 seats big air will
collect $50,000 amending the more
realistic range at a price of $300 we
see that 2,000 people will demand seats
that is want to accept the offer to
travel from Boston to New York on big
air at that price on that day and so if
it sells 2,000 tickets at $300 each big
air will collect $600,000 in revenue I
haven't said anything about their costs
yet if it raises the price more to $500
well it gets a lot of people a thousand
of those 2,000 people will still want to
pay for the seat and they'll pay $500
but of course a thousand people will
then not fly so I've constructed the
example so that big air takes in the
most money when it charges $300 it's not
free for big air to fly to New York it
has costs and as we know these costs are
very very important in figuring out when
to fly how to fly and what to charge
well I think of big air charging just
$50 that sort of crazy low price 10,000
people wanting to travel we know that
big air would have taken in five hundred
thousand dollars in revenue well what is
a cost big air to fly 10,000 people and
I've put in some huge number you know
imagine that it costs an average of $300
a person which would be three million
dollars to fly so many people why does
it cost more rather than less per seat
when it wants to fly more and more
people well to a degree when you start
increasing the number of seats that as
you increase production or output as we
call it to a degree cost drop you'll
think about the pilot following the
plane if you only have one passenger on
the plane and you've got to pay the
pilots a $1000 a day to fly the plane
that math thousand dollars is borne
entirely by that one customer sitting in
seat 1a you put 10 customers on the
plane same pilot the pilot salary can
now be spread among 10 customers so
that's relatively fixed cost of the
pilot
that fixed cost drops or it comes a less
important part of price as we have more
and more customers when big air
increases the number of passengers from
tens or thousands by dropping the price
from five thousand to five hundred it
gets what we sometimes call economies of
scale it's able to spread the pilot cost
on the airplane costs and the landing
costs and all those things I mentioned
among more and more people and so the
average cost of sending someone to New
York drops in this case from three
thousand dollars to two hundred dollars
notice it stays there for a while and
many arises once they go to ten thousand
seats and why might that be well they
probably run out of landing rights at
LaGuardia I mean where would you land
ten thousand people a day more than the
system now holds well now if we put
these two charts together we can see how
big air would make the most amount of
money that's usually its job we say that
firms are trying to maximize profits
again we imagine the firm as a rational
player that has a goal and in this case
its goal is to make as much money as
possible well look at the example when
it charges $50 and those 10,000 people
flying big air losses money it spends
three million dollars but we saw that it
takes in revenue of only $50 a seat
times 10,000 seats is $500,000 itll
loses two and a half million dollars big
air never wants to do that
what about $300 you see well that's
pretty good for big air as you can see
it yields a two hundred thousand dollar
profit big air can even do better if it
charges five hundred dollars to see even
though it only cost me gear two hundred
dollars to fly the person we can see
that here is where it maximizes its
profits hauling in three hundred
thousand dollars in net profit think
about big airs price structure there it
was able to supply the seat for $200 and
yet it figured out that it should charge
five hundred dollars from big airs point
of view if it tries to drop the price
from five hundred dollars to three
hundred dollars in a way you might think
well how could that be a bad thing
they're going to take in a thousand more
customers who are willing to pay three
hundred dollars a seat for the privilege
of flying when it only costs a big-air
two hundred dollars a seat to supply the
airplane seats so of course you'd think
big air would make more money by
lowering the price to 300 indeed and
Raisa can charge above $200 it can make
money cost me $200 to make the seat I
charge you $212 a chalk up another $12
in profit but being here in this example
is the monopolist big here's the only
one flying and so big air sees and says
to itself well wait a minute if we drop
the price from 500 to 300 in order to
capture those extra people we're given
up charging $500 to the first thousand
people we flew and it's not worth losing
two hundred thousand dollars from those
more intense desired in for marginal
customers if you will in order to make a
hundred thousand dollars from the new
thousand people who will pay $300 a seat
when the cost $200 seat to fly them so
big air instead chooses nope we will
restrict output we say and fly at $500
of seat selling just a thousand seats
rather than 2,000 seats from a social
point of view think about it from the
outside or even from the government's
point of view or the citizens Reid point
of view which is really a shame after
all the cost of the resources of flying
somebody in New York is apparently $200
and there are people out there willing
to spend more than $200 think of it as a
resource ecology thing the cost of the
resources on earth are such that for
$200 you could fly another person from
point A to point B and there's somebody
out there willing to spend $300 for it
that person has an intense preference
compared to the actual cost of doing it
but we deny them the flight we say no no
because I'm a monopolist and I can make
more money at $500 I don't want to sell
it to you at $300 economists call this a
deadweight loss they say boy that's a
shame there should be somebody there is
somebody willing to supply the sea at a
tad over $200 even 300 in our example
and there's somebody who wants to pay
300 for it and yet we're not matching
them up now you've already seen that if
this was a competition if there were 10
Airlines out there flying of course
another airline like my cookie maker
would jump right in there and say oh
come here come here we'll fly into New
York give us $300 we can fly you $400
it's a great deal but again because big
air is a monopolist it's the only one
flying this route and a demand structure
the prices are as
seen big air will choose to restrict
output to sell only a thousand seats at
$500 a seat now in the real world they
can have it both ways if you fly on an
airline and you talk to the person next
to you you might find that they've paid
much more than you paid for your seat or
much less than you've paid for your seat
big air does not quite have to charge
everybody the same for its chocolate
chip cookie if you will there is an
ability for to control arbitrage now in
this case it does it by saying your
ticket is non-refundable and
non-transferable
you can't sell back to us and just buy
another ticket when the prices drop and
similarly you can't just go to the
airport and trade it with other people
that may do this may be hiding behind a
false claim about security or
identification or something I mean it's
not entirely obvious why we let them do
that but for the time being they can do
that and this allows them to
discriminate in a way that's not meant
as a terribly bad word here to word
economists use to differentiate among
customers they are able to take the
people who want to pay a lot of money
and charge them a little bit more and
take the people who want to pay closer
to $200 and charge them less so in real
life big air discriminates among
customers you've probably also figured
out by now that that decreases rather
than increases the deadweight loss after
all it makes it more likely but big air
is selling seats that it can make for
$200 to people who are willing to pay
more than 200 a house for them because
it's already sold seeds to the $500
people and then it's able to lower the
price without people conducting
arbitrage and trading the seats so price
discrimination by a monopolist allows it
to make more money also decreases the
deadweight loss though it might get us a
little nervous for other reasons after
all the monopolist is now going to make
much much more money and there might be
people who don't like that we might
worry that the monopolist is setting
markets up on purpose in order to price
discriminate notice that the monopolist
doesn't necessarily get to keep all this
money the more clever the monopolist the
more clever the government I guess a
good government could take this money
away if it wanted to a government might
say well to the extent that we are
giving you the monopoly
Thrall we're the one that's deciding how
many planes can land in LaGuardia
instead of selling all those landing
rights the big air the government could
have set things up so big air would have
competed with American Airlines United
Airlines and so forth so if the
government gives or allows big air this
monopoly the government might say well
we want to tax away a good deal of that
money or price it away in order to use
the money for public work so to build
LaGuardia to expand the runway or what
have you
well it's easy to see how the government
does that the government might auction
off a landing rights the government
might say well we're willing to sell the
right to fly ten planes a day to
LaGuardia let's see how much you all
will pay for it so when you see a
monopoly price discriminate don't
immediately think that the monopoly is
making all that money there might be
somebody and especially the government
but able to extract a good deal of that
profit through an auction or a taxing
scheme the reason I put the example that
way is I wanted to introduce the idea
that for monopoly to thrive it needs to
have a way of preventing competitors
from entering the market sometimes we
say that monopolies thrive where there
are barriers to entry has to be
something that keeps the competitors out
in the cookie case nothing kept out new
bakeries and so as soon as the price of
cookies started rising more people
entered the market and started producing
those wonderful chocolate chip cookies
in the case of big air it's the landing
right to LaGuardia that are the barrier
to entry if the government doesn't have
any more to offer or whoever the Port
Authority that owns LaGuardia only sells
off a certain amount that's a barrier to
entry that prevents other firms from
entering iPad has patents movies have
copyright lawyers have some licenses
doctors have some licenses everywhere we
look we're the some monopoly power there
are some barriers to entry and do you
see what all these examples have in
common it's that the government the law
plays a very very big role in either
creating or sustaining these barriers to
entry
indeed we might say that while it's true
that monopolies thrive because of
barriers to entry that's what keeps the
competitors out the barriers to entry
themselves either require government
complicity or come about because of
government complicity
in our modern world big air has a funny
business it knows that it needs the
government to sustain its monopoly it
needs those landing rights at LaGuardia
not to be sold to other airlines and so
big airs most important business might
not be serving airline snacks it might
not be training pilots it might not be
learning about metal fatigue it might
actually be about learning how to get
along with government after all an
important part of its business is
retaining its monopoly getting those
landing rights at the best available
prices and maintaining them against
competition big air is in the business
of seeking help from the government it's
not something we like to say in a
capitalist society but it is something
that's true at the same time the
government which is to say our
politicians finds itself in the business
of wanting to do business with big air
think about the typical government
official the government official needs
to get reelected we need campaign
financing they need money big air is a
natural contributing to campaigns big
air wants us monopolies the government
politicians want money to run campaigns
this is a match made in heaven
or at least in the skies sometimes in
economics we call this rent-seeking the
idea refers to the fact that businesses
need to spend resources in order to get
in the position where they have the
monopoly power there is this rent they
want the monopoly profit they want that
extra money that can only come by being
a monopolist but they have to spend
money to get there and as we're about to
see in the extreme case they might spend
so much money to get that the monopolist
that they're really not much of a
monopolist at all and let's see how that
might happen
now in middle school they taught you
they taught me to the governments are
perfect that the government knows that
it needs to do what's good for the
citizenry if the government does a bad
job the voters will kick the government
out of office and get themselves some
new politicians well in that we're all
the government will decide where it
wants monopolies it might decide Oh
having only one firm land at LaGuardia
is a good idea or we need to encourage
inventors let's have patents post office
is a good thing other areas it might
decide a monopoly is a bad thing
the government might do what is in the
best interest of the economy which is to
say the citizens at large but you know
we're not in middle school anymore and
now we know that government politicians
have their own incentives and part of
their incentives is to get more money in
campaign donations part of their job is
to look for jobs for themselves and
their relatives after they're out of
office in this kind of world the
government cannot necessarily be relied
on to do what's good for its citizens
and so it's a good idea for us to keep
track of what's in it for big air what's
in it for the government and see how the
two work together
think about this someone sitting in the
White House who runs for reelection
might spend these days a billion dollars
getting reelected a billion dollars and
his opponents will probably spend about
the same amount competing for the right
to run against him and then running
against him that's two billion dollars
and resources spent on the voters it's
very unlikely that a big part of that
two billion dollars is giving us
information that we cannot otherwise get
from newspapers and other sources so
that's a kind of waste that is people
competing for our votes or competing for
attention might compete with one another
in a kind of arms race where they spend
and spend and spend in order to outdo
one another and actually there's a lot
of waste involved the same thing is true
on the other side when big air and its
competitors compete to get these landing
rights at LaGuardia
or somebody competes for the right to
build a bridge across the Mississippi
River they too might compete with each
other and they might compete so much as
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
and that's what we want to turn to next
to see how rent-seeking can be
destructive politicians spending on a
campaign would be monopolist spending
for the right to get them in
ah Blaine and country's going to war can
all be thought of in one economic model
economists sometimes call this a pay all
auction and think of the following
metaphor imagine an option in which I
bid ten dollars you bid twelve dollars
she bids fourteen dollars going going on
she gets it we call that a standard
auction or if you want to be fancy in
English auction it goes to the highest
bidder the highest bidder pays the
amount bid and the highest bidder then
gets that amount there are many other
kinds of auctions in a pay all auction I
bid ten you bid 12 she bids 14 maybe I
bid 16 then I get it for 16 but she has
to pay 14 and you have to pay the 12
that is its pay all everybody needs to
pay the amount of his or her highest bid
same thing with a campaign you spend a
lot of money on your campaign I run
against you and I spend a lot of money
running against you one of us wins none
of us gets our money back it's not like
a standard auction where if you lose at
least you don't have to pay let's
imagine big air participating in an
auction in order to get its monopoly in
the first place we already know that big
air can make a lot of money if it's the
only one flying from Boston to the
gaudiya but it has to acquire those
landing rights and imagine that the
government is auctioning off those
landing rights so one airline can fly
the route big air is willing to pay up
to 300 for it let's imagine but maybe
American Airlines is willing to pay 300
as well and maybe United is also willing
to pay 300 they can all see you can make
a lot of money being the monopolist here
now the government puts it out to bid of
course it might not do that explicitly
it might be let's say you can curry
favor with the politicians in that case
the money will really be wasted big air
might jump into the fray and spend 100
wining and dining and trying to pay off
politicians but United is not far behind
and it bids 200 and then perhaps
American airline goes for broke and it's
250 it'll only make 50 if it gets the
landing rights because it's going to
make 300 and it's now spent 250 but for
ana point of view of big air which is
already invested we might say 100 it
pays to invest another 250 that is even
though it will spend 350 altogether and
lose money on the deal right now it's
going to lose 100 have nothing to show
for it
so it might be willing to
another 250 to make the 300 well
following that logic we can see that if
Big Ear does that and actually gets the
landing rights big air will have spent
350 in order to make 300 and American
Airlines will have wasted money and
United Airlines will have wasted money
and the overall rent-seeking can really
be quite large I guess the problem could
even worse it could be trebled
politicians might change things maybe
the government knows that really the
best way to run the guardia is to have
three competing airlines but in its
quest to get all this wining and dining
in campaign contributions the government
might inefficiently set up LaGuardia
only to handle one airline in order to
get rent-seeking from the airlines so
you see how monopolies in the structure
of government begin to fit together the
monopolist gets to make more money once
it's a monopoly but in order to be a
monopoly it often needs the government's
help and in turn the government Mike
sometimes need the monopoly in order to
fuel the politicians and their
preferences this is the very unhappy
side of map I hope you're beginning to
see what a seamless web is this thing we
call economics we started out with
prices and the prices were the little
messengers that ran back and forth
coordinating supply and demand we saw
the competition was what happened in the
market to create these exchanges then we
introduced the idea of a monopolist the
monopolist had a market to himself it
was the only one selling the thing and
he could sell the item at a higher price
by cutting back on the output Alby it by
creating deadweight loss so that there
were people whose demand was unsatisfied
even though they wanted to pay a price
that the earth could supply the good for
that was the bad side of monopolies we
also saw that there might be a good side
to monopolies the government might want
monopolies to create incentives for
innovators the government might want to
monopolies to spread the letters around
through the postal service the
government in the beginning was seen as
the good player that tried to figure out
where monopolies were good and where
monopolies were bad then we introduced
complexity and saw well the government
might not be such a good player the
government might like some monopolies
and have an interest in this
rent-seeking in this play by the
monopolist to get in position where they
could charge these high prices and keep
up barriers to entry that would keep out
lower price
is in that case the government is not
the solution but part of the problem so
we have to sort of complex mix for
everything you see in government in
monopoly and competition and prices
begins to interact with wound up in the
Internet age things have turned around a
little bit we begin to appreciate the
good sides of monopolies as well first
of all we live in a global world it's
harder to be a monopolist of most Goods
because Goods can be transported from
other countries you don't just need a
monopoly in Washington or in your state
capital you need a worldwide monopoly
unless the good is very very heavy to
transport and so there's more
competition from abroad if we see
Windows 7 having a great market share we
immediately think whom I wonder if
there'll be competition from China
whereas 50 years ago people would have
seen a typewriter come out and they
would have thought all this is really a
bad monopoly because it'll be very
expensive to bring in Italian
typewriters so in a global world we're
less concerned about traditional
monopolies perhaps a little bit more
interested in intellectual property and
in those kinds of monopolies and we're
looking to see where the new competition
might come from think about prices in a
global economy how do we know where to
get things from why is iPad outsourced
to China again it's prices that are
travelling the globe Apple wants a
component it tries to figure out who can
make that most cheaply the component can
be made most cheaply in one location
people will pay more for the iPad in
another location
the price is raced back and forth faster
than the iPad and the iPad eventually
finds its way from the maker to the
end-user a prices are there for a way to
think about countries in their role in
the world economy think in this case
about your future where India and China
are the growing economic powers of the
day and think how different those
economies are and how they rely on
monopoly rent seeking and prices it's a
good example for us of things that we've
learned
let's take the case of China first China
is not outwardly a capitalist economy
though it has a lot of capitalism in it
it brilliantly uses local governments in
competition with one another so local
government officials want to be promoted
they want to make it to the Central
Committee they want to get more payments
they do this by showing that in their
region of the country standards of
living arising people are safer there
aren't a lot of deaths from earthquakes
or industrial accidents and so forth
competition among local governments
seems to be the key of what makes China
work prices helped China interact with
the rest of the world but within China
power relationships and competition
seems to be what makes it work it's a
top-down economy in a way where people
at the grassroots are operating in order
to advance in power and wealth India is
a very very different kind of economy in
the Indian economy the government
famously has trouble producing
infrastructure so there are many cities
in India where upper-middle class people
and certainly wealthy people are paying
for health education even water in the
private market there's nominally a
government supplied system but then
there's a very male well developed
grassroot system where entrepreneurs
step in where government fails and
entrepreneurs offer goods in that kind
of system prices play a key role if I
want water and I want clean water I go
see who provides the water best in China
if I want water and the water is bad I
hold the strike and I complain and then
the media pick up on it and the local
government official is embarrassed and
says all people here have unrest unrest
is a terrible thing and before the local
official can be slapped out of position
by the central party the local official
has an incentive to supply water better
and improve the infrastructure India
prices and markets China power
rent-seeking monopoly competition among
these monopolies the government
comparing them one to another we don't
know which works better China takes your
breath away if you're an economist if
you're an economist in my generation you
were brought up thinking that central
planning fails only markets can do the
job and only prices as messengers
running around that's the only way to
make the world go faster and now
suddenly we find that our major economic
it's really only using prices modestly
instead of using non-price things
including power structures and
promotions to fuel the economy and
they're not bad at it there are roads
and china and factories and railroads
and gas supplies fantastic and bridges
go up and buildings go up quickly and
they're not going up quickly because a
little prices running around as messages
they're going up quickly because a very
clever government that is thought about
rent seeking and thought about how to
eliminate corruption and wining and
dining has tried to figure out how to
get people to compete that the buildings
there will go up faster better and safer
than the buildings over there it's a
very very impressive feat and it's a big
challenge for economics and your
generation economics is now a tool for
you economics is the way you're going to
improve the world around you economics
is the way you're going to understand
your cell phone carrier and why taxis
cost what they do and why drinking
straws are free why they supply them
with some drinks and not others you're
going to understand travel better and
the world better and foreign affairs
better go learn more about it go
understand the world about you and go
make it a better place thank you very
much and good luck